imagine knowing that there's a monster
right under your nose imagine knowing
that this monster is capable of killing
any human being on earth and all because
they simply saw a photograph of its face
when this monster is on the warpath
literally nothing can stop it no weapon
that human beings have invented is
capable of even slowing it down
imagine knowing in the age of mass media
of clicks and shares of 24-hour news
smartphones and limitless social media
connecting billions across the globe
that one stray picture of this monster
leaked in the wrong place could cause
the end of the world as we know it and
this fateful terrifying day could come
at any time congratulations
you now know how it feels to be dr dan
the hot-headed lead scp foundation
researcher on the scp-096
case the anomaly itself requires no real
introduction the infamous mass murdering
shy guy has haunted the nightmares of
foundation experts for years but nobody
is more haunted by this thing than dr
dan himself for over a decade now he has
firmly believed that there's one
solution to the 096 problem termination
with extreme prejudice in his eyes to
think that 096 is ever truly contained
is an illusion they could never be sure
of how many pictures of it are out there
floating around just waiting to be seen
like a time bomb waiting to go off the
resources spent containing it and
cleaning up after its rampages he would
often argue would be better spent
instead figuring out how to finally kill
it but seeing as we're talking about the
scp foundation here not the global
occult coalition the o5 council didn't
see it quite the same way they
constantly overturned dr dan's
termination requests leaving the
paranoid researcher more furious with
each rejection he tried to warn them
again and again
and again
don't you see it's like a stick of
dynamite and the fuse is already lit if
you don't let me put it out before it's
too late there won't even be anyone left
to pick up the pieces but his pleas fell
on deaf ears until of course incident
096-1-a a dark and bloody day still
looked back on with shame and horror by
even the most hardened members of
foundation staff it was the day that
scp-019 gave everyone a taste of the
mass carnage it was truly capable of dr
dan wasn't even there when containment
was first breached he was off on an
expedition in the snowy mountains where
096 was first found trying to discover
clues to its true origin dr dan's second
in command dr alexi was also lucky
enough to be outside of the containment
area when the shy guy escaped according
to interviews he gave at debriefing
tribunals he was in the break room
treating himself to a warm cup of joe
all the other personnel assigned to
096's containment and research were near
its containment chamber a giant cube
made of reinforced metal observing a
live feed of data being collected from
the cube's interior as usual sensors
indicated that 096 was pacing within for
obvious reasons the foundation doesn't
maintain any kind of live visual
surveillance on nine sex it wouldn't be
worth the risk but what seemed like in
otherwise quiet days suddenly took a
turn for the insane the monitors began
displaying terrifying data indicating an
imminent containment breach as the
whales of the creature within the cube
echoed out through its metal walls some
tried to run others did all they could
to engage emergency procedures while
guards armed with heavy weaponry rushed
into the room they all knew in their
hearts that it wouldn't save them but
what else could they do a huge dent
bulged out from the side of the cube
then another before the metal was torn
open like tissue paper as the furious
hands of the shy guy began clawing their
way through it secondary layers of
protection were deployed but they didn't
help 096 just kept ripping through all
the barriers as everyone in attendance
knew once it was in its rage state
nothing could stop it literally
nothing the guards attempted to fire on
the anomaly but their bullets did no
good as the creature burst free most of
the people in the room had at least
momentary visual contact with its face
and response code lima was declared and
the entire chamber was flooded with a
fast-acting nerve gas killing everyone
everyone except for 096 itself of course
within two minutes 096 had broken free
of the entire containment site and began
running through the desert at breakneck
speeds towards its distant target the
foundation needed to act fast and find a
way to stop it before it hit a
population center where the death toll
would skyrocket team echo romeo were
dispatched to pursue the creature in a
heavily armed attack helicopter while
mtf tau-1 a task force specializing in
scp-096 containment and recovery forged
ahead to identify the anomaly's target
designated 096-a
and to move any other civilians out of
harm's way dr dan was alerted of the
disastrous situation and offered
guidance to both teams from afar echo
romeo's chopper pursued 096 barely able
to keep up dr dan recommended attempting
to at least slow the creature down with
heavy arms fire even though he knew
actually stopping it would be impossible
a member of the team used a modified
xm500 anti-materiel rifle to fire
several rounds of the creature but even
the shot that passed directly through
its head appeared to have no effect on
it but at least they had a lock on its
direction now 096 always travels in a
straight line directly towards its
target smashing through any obstacles in
its way this means its intended
direction is relatively easy to track
and people in the path of its trajectory
are even easier to save but it's a high
pressure job reserve for mtf tau one tau
one passed over echo romeo and 096 in
the series of eight v-22 ospreys hoping
beyond hope that they could outrun the
creature since there were several
different towns in its direct path but
thanks once again to the one and only dr
dan echo romeo and tao 1 had a secret
weapon that neither team had ever
possessed before scramble scramble was
an advanced computer program created by
dr dan with the help of dr alexi which
was coded into microprocessors for
modification into camera feeds and
viewing goggles the program had been fed
intricate data concerning every single
detail of 096's face and as the name
suggests when encountering that visual
data in real life it scrambles it beyond
recognition in theory it would make it
far safer for operatives to be around
scp-096 without activating its rage
state in theory it wasn't long before
disaster struck 096 had made its way
onto i-40 and had begun attacking
vehicles it encountered killing the
people inside by this point it had
already outrun the echo romeo chopper
rendering them essentially useless tau-1
just had to forge ahead along 0-9-6's
trajectory and try to get as many people
out of the danger zone as possible until
096-1 was located and destroyed by the
anomaly years of training for an awful
day like this had paid off as the first
three towns along 096's path were
successfully evacuated the shy guy just
ran right through all of them and no
lives were lost the same however could
not be said for town number four as was
standard procedure tau1 had everyone in
the town gathered up and blindfolded the
entire team in attendance had modified
night vision goggles with scramble
microprocessors so in theory they were
better off than most from 096 if things
went south the tau-1 members tried in
vain to keep everybody in line they were
threatening to shoot anyone who dared to
remove their blindfold when 096 finally
appeared it tripped during its approach
rolling and shattering through several
houses chaos erupted some people
instinctively removed their blindfolds
to see what was going on and panic
members of taowan began firing into the
crowd the screams of the civilians and
the bursts of gunfire were all drowned
out by the horrific wailing of 096
itself as it tore through everyone and
everything to kill the unfortunate souls
who had seen its face and given how many
had removed their blindfolds during the
initial pandemonium
scp-096 had a huge number of the
townspeople on its list 096 located and
grabbed the original 096-1
the person that had first glimpsed its
face and caused all of this but in the
grand scheme of things he was just one
more body on the pile that day
though of course we mean this in a
purely metaphorical sense zero nine six
never leaves entire bodies the
foundation operatives in attendance were
able to figure out what had caused all
this madness and death
096-1 had been an amateur mountaineer
and spent his vacations hiking around
any mountain ranges he could gain access
to including the mountain range that 096
had been inhabiting prior to its initial
capture and containment but he hadn't
actually seen 096 on that fateful trip
which had been taken over a decade ago
but in a photograph taken that day of
himself standing on a picturesque
mountainside 096 made a cameo it took up
all of four pixels a tiny off-white dot
against the snow on the back right side
of the photograph this photograph with
all the deadly potency of an atom bomb
had been sitting there for years
waiting when the mountaineer was looking
through old photos that morning and his
eyes passed over those few blurry pixels
he didn't have any idea that he had just
laid his eyes on one of the most
dangerous anomalies the world has ever
seen but you don't have to know
only096
does as tao 1 led by their commander
major jack wilford tried to retake
control of the situation things got even
worse it turned out dr dan's scramble
technology the one thing that was
supposed to have given them an edge in
this situation didn't actually work as
soon as goggle-wearing members of the
team laid eyes on 096 it entered its
rage state and started massacring them
it tore many of the mobile task force
members to shreds including a number of
the operatives required for piloting the
eight ospreys it was a disaster of truly
epic proportions and the catastrophic
failure of dr dan's scramble technology
was a key factor the root of the
technology's failure was easy enough to
figure out
dr dan's scramble microprocessors worked
fast but not fast enough fractions of a
second glimpses of 096's face managed to
get through and that was more than
enough to set 096 off echo romeo and mtf
epsilon arrived shortly afterwards to
clean up the mess it'd been a disaster
of such magnitude that even a cnn
reporter arrived on the scene and
started filming before being promptly
shut down by epsilon it was a member of
echo romeo that finally slipped the bag
over a docile 096's head preparing it
for containment once again the creature
now content that it had eliminated all
the unfortunate souls who had seen its
face he'd found 096 sitting next to a
minivan that had its roof ripped off the
young family inside being the last to
have seen its face and things were so
awful in the aftermath of the
containment breach that the o5 council
changed their tune finally granting dr
dan permission to terminate 096 by any
means necessary it's terrifying to think
that all this can unfold because of a
couple of poorly timed accidents but
it's probably even more terrifying to
consider that it wasn't an accident at
all it seemed awfully convenient that
both dr dan and dr alexi were far from
danger when all hell broke loose it was
also convenient that despite the failure
of his technology being a major reason
why the breach was as deadly as it was
dr dan had still come out of the
situation with everything he wanted the
foundation also found this strange and
the more they looked into it the more
they found details that didn't add up
alibis began to fall apart coincidences
didn't seem so coincidental and
eventually a weak link in the chain was
identified dr o'lexi under pressure from
the foundation alexi spilled everything
dr dan had essentially orchestrated the
entire containment breach and on top of
that he did everything he could to make
it as deadly as possible all with the
purpose of getting the o5 council to see
things his way and finally give him the
permission he needed to devote all of
the
scp-096 resources to its termination but
it came at a terrible price to dr dan
personally for his crimes against the
foundation and humanity he was permitted
to try and figure out a way to terminate
096 once and for all but as payment for
his crimes he himself would also be
terminated as soon as his task was
complete with the lies of all those
innocent people and dr dan himself worth
the price of finally being authorized to
terminate
scp-096 when asked why he did all of
this dr dan simply said it worked there
was only a matter of time until that
happened in a major population center
and its face spread over the world news
i can kill 096 but i've killed myself in
the process while we don't agree with
his methods there's something almost
admirable about a person so
single-mindedly devoted to their cause
now check out
scp-096 the shy guy and
scp-096 look at a picture of the shy guy
in space the shy guy questions and
theories if you're still itching for
another 096 fix